ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARRILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible] EIGHT MEN
[inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMóN OWN
[inaudible]
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
STONE.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
IS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
HOW CAN I BE HAPPY?
THE SPIRITUAL TRADITIONS OF
HUMANITY ALL REMIND US TO
DISCOVER THAT ARE REAL HAPPINESS
EMERGES WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO
TRANSCEND ARE SELF CENTERED
MINES.
WHEN WE DO THAN HAPPINESS AND
CONTENTMENT NATURALLY MANIFESTS?
ARCHBISHOP DESMOND TUTU SAID.
I THINK ALMOST ALL OF US ARE
SURPRISED OUR JOY IS ENHANCED
WHEN WE MAKE SOMEONE ELSE HAPPY.
THEN HE ADDED I HOPE THE PEOPLE
WOULD RECOGNIZE IN THEMSELVES.
THAT IT IS WHEN WE ARE CLOSED IN
ON OURSELVES THAT WE TEND TO BE
MISERABLE.
IT IS WHEN WE GROW IN SELF
FORGETFULNESS.
IN A REMARKABLE WAY WE DISCOVER
THAT WE ARE FILLED WITH JOY.
THIS SELF FORGETFULNESS
ARCHBISHOP TO TO SPEAKS OF IS
SIMPLY TO BECOME ON CENTERED ON
OURSELVES.
ROOMY TRUNK TO ENSURE ZEN
MASTERS WOULD ALL AGREE WITH
ARCHBISHOP DESMOND TUTU WHEN HE
SAYS WHEN WE GROW IN SELF
FORGETFULNESS.
WE DISCOVER THAT WE ARE FILLED
WITH JOY.
THEY REPRESENT DIVERSE AND
DEEPLY SPIRITUAL TRADITIONS OF
HUMANITY.
WHEN WE GROW IN SELF
FORGETFULNESS?
WE WILL REACH ROOMIES FIELD
BEYOND RIGHT AND WRONG.
CHUNG FUSE MINE WHERE THERE IS
NO FOR OR AGAINSTTHERE WILL BE
NO ARBITRARY LINES DRAWN IN THE
GROUND.
AFFECTING OUR ABILITY TO EMBRACE
THE ONE NESS OF LIFE.
NOW MORE AMENABLE.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER MAJOR.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS -- IS A LITTLE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY SECOND
NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT TEN I
AM ON OH KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEM ASSEMBLY RESIDING
CHEAPER DEDUCTIBLES AND AT THE
DESK.
READING CLICK KATHLEEN AND LUIS
READING.
CALDERON MOVES AND MR FLORA
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN SHARON QUIRK SILVA. FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN KILEY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
JAY OBERNOLTE AND FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL MURATSUCHI.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE EIGHTEEN A
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO.
REQUEST THAT AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEM
THREE A. B. FOURTEEN ANYONE
GRAYSON TO THE ACT FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ON RECONSIDERATION ITEMS ONE AND
TWO ARE TO BE CONTINUED.
WE ARE THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS [inaudible]
THREE THROUGH.
TEN PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
ELEVEN THIS IS A C. R. SIXTY TWO
BY MS Là M<c.cyan> ON THE CLERK</c>
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LIMóN AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA ON PROFITS DAY.
MS LIMóN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IS THE CHAIR OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
ON THE NONPROFIT SECTOR TO
PROUDLY PRESENT ACR ONE NINETY
ONE WHICH IT CLEARS JUNE FIFTH
TWENTY NINETEEN AS CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT STAY IN RECOGNITION OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO THE ECONOMY AND
WELL BEING.
OF OUR STATE.
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA OUR STRONG ECONOMIC
POWERS.
THEY RANKED AS THE FOURTH
LARGEST INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEE NEARLY ONE
MILLION INDIVIDUALS AND GENERATE
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT BILLION IN
ANNUAL REVENUE.
THIS WEDNESDAY JUNE FIFTH WE
WILL HONOR OVER A HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE NATIONAL
AND INTERNATIONAL GROUND
BREAKERS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
SCIENCE SAFETY NET ANIMATION
CIVIL RIGHTS.
ARTS IN HUMANITIES AND THE
PURSUIT OF DEMOCRATIC IDEALS.
THE ENSURE PEOPLE DO NOT GO
HUNGRY WATCH OUR CHILDREN AFTER
SCHOOL HE'LL COMMUNITIES DIVIDED
AND PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
ASSISTANCE AFTER NATURAL
DISASTERS.
THERE ARE SO MANY REASONS WHY
NOW IS AN EXCITING YET
CHALLENGING TIME TO BE AND THE
NONPROFIT IN CALIFORNIA I URGE
AN AYE VOTE AND HOW THAT WOULD.
BE OPEN TO THE FIRST -- ROLE
BEING OPEN TO THE CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MS LEMOND MISTER
MEDINA YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TO
DIE TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR.
SIX SIXTY TWO CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS DELIVER
SERVICES TO THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WHILE IMPROVING
QUALITY OF LIFE.
EXPRESSING COMMUNITY VALUES AND
PROMOTING SOCIAL CHANGE.
CODEC IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF SUCH
A NONPROFIT IN MY DISTRICT.
TODA X. MISSION IS TO EMPOWER
MARGINALIZED IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES TO BECOME
ECONOMICALLY SOCIALLY
EDUCATIONALLY AND CIVIC LEE SELF
SUFFICIENT WHILE ENHANCING
INDIVIDUALS SELF ESTEEM.
AND COMMUNITY HEALTH.
NONPROFIT STRIVE TO SOLVE BASIC
HUMAN ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS AN
IMPORTANT POTENTIALLY LIFE
THREATENING PROBLEMS AND ISSUES.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA BARBARA. FOR
RECOGNIZING JUNE FIFTH.
AS CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT DAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
SEN NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MS Là MONIS ASSET THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON A C. R.. SIXTY TWO
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR FIFTY EIGHT
NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE AC ARE.
EIGHTY TWO CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS A
RELATIVE TO ALZHEIMER'S AND
BRAIN AWARENESS MONTH AND THE
LONGEST DAY.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT A C. R.
EIGHTY TWO WHICH DECLARES THE
MONTH OF JUNE AS ALZHEIMER'S AND
BRAIN AWARENESS MONTH.
END OF THE SUMMER SOLSTICE THIS
YEAR ON JUNE TWENTY FIRST AS THE
LONGEST DAY.
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS A
PROGRESSIVE BRAIN DISORDER THE
TRAGICALLY ROB'S INDIVIDUALS OF
THEIR MEMORIES.
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS ALWAYS
FATAL AND TODAY IT IS THE THIRD
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AFRICAN AMERICANS LATINOS AND
WOMEN ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
MANY OF US KNOW PEOPLE IN OUR
LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY
THE DISTANCE DISEASE.
I WELCOME MANY PEOPLE TODAY BUT
I WANT TO PRESS. TO ANNOUNCE I
HAVE ONE OF MY GOOD FRIENDS HERE
TODAY PAM.
WHO IS LEADING THE CHARGE OF
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT ALZHEIMER'S IS
ABOUT AND PREVENTED OF BOYS TO
WORK WITH THAT?
ACR ACR EIGHTY TWO REFORMS THE
ASSEMBLY IS COMMITMENT TO
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC ON THE
STILL.
THE BILL ATTAINING DISEASE A
REMINDS US OF THE NEED TO
INCREASE OUR EFFORTS TO COMBAT
IT'S HUMAN AND ECONOMIC COSTS.
I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN CO
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU IS AGUIAR-CURRY MISTER
COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES IS SO GOOD TO JOIN
YOU ON THE FLOOR TODAY I JUST
WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
I LOST MY MOM DOORS LEE COOLEY.
TO ALZHEIMER'S IN [inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND YEAH I
JUST KNOW THIS IS A VERY
DIABOLICAL THING.
IT AFFECTS THE PERSON BUT THE
PERSON STILL THERE [inaudible]
AND WE LOOK FOR RESEARCH TO
CONTINUE TO HELP US UNDERSTAND
THE MYSTERY THIS DISEASE TO FIND
A WAY TO HELP PEOPLE.
AND THAT -- I GUESS I WOULD JUST
PRAY FOR ALL PERSONALS
ALZHEIMER'S THAT THEY WILL
REMEMBER.
IT DOES AFFECT THE MEMORY.
BUT THAT THEY WILL REMEMBER THAT
THEY ARE LOVED -- SO I JUST URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY DOCTOR
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE SO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
WAYS HE ARE -- EIGHTY TWO THIS
TERRIBLE DEVASTATING DISEASES
ALZHEIMER'S -- OF THIS.
A SOLUTION OR TO REMIND US THAT
THE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS SO.
AND THE WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE AND
TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN.
PULL RESEARCH TO COME UP WITH
THE PREVENTION AND TO CURE OF
THIS DISEASE.
MY MUD THE NINETY FIVE YEARS OLD --
AND SHE IS ALSO -- SUFFERING
FROM MARSHALL MEMORY --
DIFFICULTIES SO HAND ON THAT
ASSIGNMENT IS A WHOLE TERRIBLE
REPAIR ALL CV OR CASES SO --
THAT I HEAR ALL OF LAW SO I
THINK THAT THIS IS SAW NOT JUST --
SOMEONE -- SPECIAL BUT IT IS
SELF FOR JUST.
ABOUT EVERYONE THAT THE WE ARE
EXPOSED TO AND THE WE MAY -- BE
AT THE RISK OF SUFFERING THIS
KIND OF ALL.
A TERRIBLE DISEASE SO THEREFORE
I THINK OUR STATE HAS TO PAY
ATTENTION TO IT AND THE TO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN.
DO IN HAND SO RESEARCH AND TO
COME UP WITH THE CURE I STRONGLY
URGE YOU A STRONG -- I'VE WORKED.
THANK YOU JACK CHOI.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM IS
AGUIAR-CURRY SASS AT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS MS
AGUIAR-CURRY MAKE CLOTHES WE
WISH.
I SIMPLY ASKED HER I VOTED TO
REMEMBER ALL THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN AFFLICTED WITH ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THING IS AGUIAR-CURRY THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
IS FOR COAUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ADDING ONTO A C. R. EIGHTY TWO
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
WE RETURNED TO YOU FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION
RELATIVE TO THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO INTRODUCE OUR LARGE
GROUP OF GUESTS HERE IN THE
GALLERY TODAY FROM THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION.
THERE ARE WEARING PURPLE TO
RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND A
RECOGNIZED JUNE AS ALZHEIMER'S
AWARENESS MONTH.
MANY OF YOU WILL BE MEETING WITH
THEM IN YOUR OFFICES TODAY.
I WANT YOU TO ASK THEM THE
QUESTIONS THOSE TOUGH QUESTIONS
AND THEY WILL HAVE THE ANSWERS
FOR YOU ON HOW WE CAN IDENTIFY.
THIS DISEASE EARLY ON LET'S GIVE
THEM A WARM WELCOME WITH IT TO
THE ASSEMBLY AND THANK THEM FOR
JOINING US TO RECOGNIZE THIS
MONTH
.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN PASS RETAIN WEIRD
FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN ACR EIGHTY ONE BY
MISTER GIBSON CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY ONE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GIPSON RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
FISHING AND BOATING WEEK.
MISTER GIBSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR.
EIGHTY ONE WOULD DECLARE THE
WEEK OF JUNE FIRST THROUGH JUNE
NINTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IS
CALIFORNIA.
FISHING FISHING AND BOATING WEEK
RECREATIONAL BOATING IS VITAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WITH ANNUAL
IMPACT AT THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDING.
NEARLY FORTY TWO THOUSAND JOBS.
NEARLY THREE THOUSAND BUSINESSES
THIS IS THE SECOND LARGEST
STUDENT THE SECOND HIGHEST
BOATING IMPACT IN THE UNITED
STATES ECONOMY SECOND TO ONLY
FLORIDA.
SPORTS FISHING IS VITAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S TOURIST ECONOMY
WITH TWO MILLION FISHERMAN'S
SPENDING TWO POINT NINE BILLION
AND SUPPORTING OVER THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND JOBS.
EVERY YEAR BORDERS AND FISSURES
FISHERMAN'S CONTRIBUTE ONE POINT
SIX BILLION IN TAXES THESE TAXES
FUNDS CONSERVATION'S RESTORATION
EFFORTS TO PRESERVING OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS PERSONALLY.
I AM A FISHERMAN I HOST ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE RUN DOLLY
OFFICIALLY A LEGISLATIVE OF FISH
FRY EACH YEAR AT MISTER CARTY IS
HOME -- MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE ON AC ARE.
EIGHTY ONE THERE WAS GIVE SENT
MISTER PATTERSON.
THANK WAS SPEAKER MEMBERS I I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT WITH --
MEMBER GIPSON ODD.
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW MUCH
FUN -- THIS -- THIS GRANT HAS
WITH HIS GRANDKIDS FISHING.
I SPEND SOMETHING THAT I'VE DONE --
SINCE I WAS YOUNG.
I DID WITH MY MY MY KIDS AND NOW
WITH MY GRANDKIDS.
AND IT'S AN EXCITING AND VERY
FUN OPPORTUNITY BOATING AND
FISHING IS A WONDERFUL
RECREATION OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND
REALLY GREAT TIMES.
OUT WITH THE PEOPLE THAT WE LOVE.
AND CALIFORNIA PROVIDE SOME REAL
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITIES I HAPPEN
TO REPRESENT.
OTHER KINGS RIVER WATERSHED IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER WATERSHED.
IT'S NOT ONLY A OF AN OPPORTUNE
TO SAVE IN STORE AND MOVE WATER
FOR AGRICULTURE AND PEOPLE AND
ALL OF THAT.
BUT IT'S A GREAT AND WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO FISH UP AND DOWN
THE KINGS RIVER WHETHER YOU'RE
ALL THE WAY UP TO THE TO THE TO
THE FOR THE WATER HAD.
OR DOWN A PINE FLAK LAKE ON THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER WE FISH ALL
THE WAY UP TO THE TO THE WATER
HAD A PICK UP UP THE SAN JOAQUIN
AND AND A MILITANT LAKE.
AND PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA COME TO OUR AREAS --
TO FISH AND TO ENJOY THE
WILDLIFE SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS.
ARE PARTICULARLY ON BEHALF OF OF
THE FUN THAT CHAIRMAN I HAVE --
FISHING -- WITH NO AND JENNA.
M. AND JOVI AND LAST IN OUR FOR
OUR FOR GRAND BABIES IT'S A
GREAT JOY THANK YOU MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD STRONG
SUPPORT.
FAMOUS PATTERSON SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF THE
RESOLUTION.
MISTER GIBSON YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS OF THE FIRST ROLES ARE
RIGHT.
MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
AUTHORS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
PARK WELL CLOSER ALL THERE ARE
SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS AT ON THE
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. FIVE FIFTEEN PASS
AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN IS H. R.
THIRTY NINE BY MISS THEM ON
KERKORIAN.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER LIMON RELATIVE TO
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT
[inaudible]
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO
PROBABLY BRING YOU HOUSE
RESOLUTION.
THIRTY NINE A RESOLUTION
CELEBRATING THE PASSAGE OF WHAT
WOULD BECOME THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION.
IN OUR U. S. CONGRESS A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO.
BUT THE HISTORY OF WOMEN EARNING
THE RIGHT TO VOTE GOES BACK MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS.
IN JULY EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT
REFORMERS ELIZABETH CADY STANTON
AND LUCRETIA MOTT ORGANIZED THE
FIRST WOMEN'S RIGHTS CONVENTION
AT SENECA FALLS IN NEW YORK.
TWENTY YEARS LATER IN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE THE NATIONAL WOMEN
SUFFERING SUFFRAGE ASSOCIATION
LED BY SUSAN B. ANTHONY AND
ELIZABETH CADY STANTON WAS
FORMED TO ADVOCATE.
ON AMENDMENTS THAT TO THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION THAT WOULD
GRANT WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
IN THAT SAME YEAR A POWERFUL
ACTIVIST LUCY STONE FORMED THE
AMERICAN WOMAN SUFFRAGE
ASSOCIATION TO PURSUE A STATE BY
STATE STRATEGY TO PASS SUCH AN
AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION.
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THESE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS WERE UNITED TO
CREATE THE NATIONAL AMERICAN
WOMAN SUFFRAGE ASSOCIATION.
AND THE FIGHT FOR WOMEN
CONTINUED.
AS WITH MANY THINGS.
AS OF MANY GREAT THINGS THAT
POLICY STARTED IN CALIFORNIA THE
WORDING OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT WAS FIRST INTRODUCED
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE IN
JANUARY EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR AARON SERGEANT FROM
CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR SERGEANT WAS AN
OUTSPOKEN WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE
ADVOCATE HE TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
UNITED STATES SENATE IN SUPPORT
OF THE AMENDMENT ALONG SIDE
FEMALE ACTIVISTS HOWEVER THE
PROPOSAL WAS REJECTED BY YOU THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
IN A SIXTEEN TO THIRTY FOUR VOTE
IN. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
YEARS LATER IN NINETEEN SIXTEEN
ALICE PAUL CHAIR OF THE
WASHINGTON DC COMMITTEE.
OF THE NATIONAL AMERICAN WOMAN
SUFFRAGE ASSOCIATION CREATED THE
NATIONAL WOMAN'S PARTY A
POLITICAL PARTY ADVOCATING FOR
THE PASSAGE OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT.
THESE INCREDIBLE WOMEN WERE THE
FIRST WOMAN IN HISTORY TO PICK
AT THE WHITE HOUSE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN IN HIS
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN ADDRESS THE U.
S. SENATE. TO THE U. S. SENATE
PRESIDENT WOODROW WILSON
RECOGNIZE THE INCREASED ROLE OF
AMERICAN WOMEN WERE PLAYING IN
OUR SOCIETY.
AND YET IT TOOK ANOTHER YEAR
BEFORE CONGRESS WOULD PASS A
RESOLUTION TO APPROVE THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT.
IT PASSED BY A LARGE MARGIN IN
THE US HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
IN MAY ON MAY TWENTY FIRST
NINETEEN NINETEEN BUT ONLY
PASSED BY TWO VOTES IN THE U. S.
SENATE ENGINE ON JUNE FOURTH.
NINETEEN NINETEEN THE AMENDMENT
WAS THEN SENT THE UNITED STATES
TO THE STATES FOR RATIFICATION.
ALTHOUGH SOME STATE LEGISLATURES
OPPOSED TO WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WAS NOT
ONE OF THEM.
ON NOVEMBER FIRST NINETEEN
NINETEEN THEN GOVERNOR WILLIAM
D. STEPHENS CALLED THE SPECIAL
SPECIAL SESSION.
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO RATIFY THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE PASSED
THE AMENDMENT ON THAT SAME DAY.
IT CAN ALSO BE NOTED THAT
CALIFORNIA GRANTED WOMEN THE
RIGHT TO VOTE NEARLY A DECADE
BEFORE IT WAS THE LAW OF OUR
NATION.
TODAY ALL FIFTY STATES HAVE
RATIFIED THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION WHICH STATES THAT.
THE RIGHTS OF CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES TO VOTE SHALL NOT
BE DENIED.
OR ABRIDGED BY ANY UNITED STATES
OR BY.
ANY STATE ON ACCOUNT OF SEX
GUARANTEEING WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
LET'S LET US CELEBRATE TODAY AS
WE MARK THIS HISTORIC MOMENT
THIS WAS NOT AN EASY BATTLE AND
IT WAS A BATTLE THAT CONTINUED
FOR DECADES UNTIL WE AS WOMEN
GUARANTEED THAT.
ALL WOMEN INCLUDING WOMEN OF
COLOR WOULD FIND OURSELVES FREE
TO VOTE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
THE FIRST CALL TO BE OPEN TO ADD
A CO AUTHORS AND THEN ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON HR THIRTY NINE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
THANK YOU MISS AMOUNT MISS
WALDRON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AS THE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHTH
WOMAN ELECTED TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HR.
THIRTY NINE A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
VOTE WAS IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWED BY
WOMEN REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITIES THEY LIVE IN.
I AS WELL AS THE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE OTHER WOMEN HAVE THAT
HAVE BEEN ELECTED TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE OVER THE PAST
HUNDRED YEARS -- BUT WHEN YOU
CONTRAST THAT WITH OVER.
FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
MEMBERS HAVE SERVED IN OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE WE FALLS FAR SHORT
OF THE NUMBERS THAT WE NEED TO
BE REPRESENTING US HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO WOMEN FAR
FOR QUALITY AND TODAY WHILE BIG
STRIDES HAVE BEEN MADE THERE IS
STILL WORK TO DO.
PAY EQUITY CONTINUES TO BE AN
ISSUE MORE REPRESENTATION ON
ELECTED BOARDS COUNCILS AND
LEGISLATURE'S.
STILL FALLS SHORT.
AS WE RECOGNIZE THE RIGHT OF
WOMEN TO VOTE WE CELEBRATE THE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF WINNING
THAT FIGHT.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO
HONOR THEM TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS WALTER MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR.
THIRTY NINE AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION TO THE
FLOOR.
MANY WOMEN AND ALLIES HAVE
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO IMPROVE THE
WORLD FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS.
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WAS A
HUGE VICTORY FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS
BUT IT WAS JUST ONE STEP IN
GAINING EQUALITY FOR ALL WOMEN.
THE FIGHT CONTINUED AS WOMEN IN
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO A.
P. I. AND INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES
FOUGHT FOR THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOR
DECADES AFTER THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT WAS PASSED.
TODAY THE BATTLE TO ATTAIN EQUAL
RIGHTS AND EQUAL PAY STILL
PERSISTS WOMEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY FACE BARRIERS
IN EDUCATION AND IN EMPLOYMENT.
NOW IS THE TIME TO REFLECT ON
THE COURAGE AND THE RESILIENCE
OF THOSE WHO HAVE COME BEFORE US.
AND TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS
STILL SO MUCH WORK TO BE DONE.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
EQUAL ACCESS TO EDUCATION EQUAL
PAY FOR COMPARABLE WORK ACCESS
TO CHILDCARE AND FAMILY FRIENDLY
WORKPLACES.
WE MUST FIGHT JUST TO BE SEEN.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I JOIN
MY COLLEAGUE IN SUPPORT OF HR
THIRTY NINE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
MINS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION
GRANTED AMERICAN WOMEN THE RIGHT
TO VOTE.
RATIFIED ON AUGUST EIGHTEENTH
NINETEEN TWENTY AND DURING
ALMOST A CENTURY OF PROTEST.
IN DURING AMERICA'S EARLY
HISTORY WOMEN WERE DENIED THE
BASIC RIGHTS ENJOYED BY MALE
CITIZENS MARRIED WOMAN THEY
COULDN'T OWN PROPERTY THEY HAD
NO LEGAL CLAIM TO THE MONEY THAT
THEY MIGHT EARN.
AND THEY HAD NO RIGHT TO VOTE.
AND THEY'RE EXPECTED TO FOCUS ON
HOUSEWORK AND RAISING THE
CHILDREN RATHER THAN POLITICS.
THE IDEA OF VOTING RIGHTS WAS
MARKED BY THE MEDIA IT WAS
MARKED.
BY THE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THE SUFFRAGE MOVEMENT GATHERED
ENOUGH STEAM TO INFLUENCE AN
INFLUENCE TO LOBBY CONGRESS FOR
A CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
CONGRESS RESPONDED BY DOING WHAT
GOVERNMENT BODIES DO BY SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO FORM.
A COMMISSION AND WE'RE GONNA
STUDY IT.
AND THEY STUDY THAT.
AND WHEN THE PROPOSAL FINALLY
REACHED THE SENATE FLOOR IN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX IT WAS
DEFEATED BY TWO VOTES.
BUT THOSE WHO WERE DETERMINED TO
SECURE THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOR
WOMEN DID NOT GIVE UP THANKFULLY.
ON MAY TWENTY FIRST NINETEEN
NINETEEN U. S. REPRESENTATIVE
JAMES R. MANN A REPUBLICAN FROM
ILLINOIS IN THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SUFFRAGE COMMITTEE.
PROPOSED THE HOUSE RESOLUTION TO
APPROVE AMENDMENT GRANTING WOMEN
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
IN THE MEASURE FINALLY PASSED
THE HOUSE.
IN JUNE OF NINETEEN NINETEEN IN
JUNE OF NINETEEN NINETEEN THE
SENATE VOTED ON THE AMENDMENT
GIVEN THEM GIVING THE WOMEN THE
RIGHT TO VOTE.
THE VOTE CAME AFTER FOUR HOURS
OF DEBATE.
DURING WHICH SOME DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS OPPOSE THE AMENDMENT
AND TRIED TO FILIBUSTER. TO
PREVENT IT FROM GETTING TO ROLL
CALL THAT.
THAT.
THAT FAILED CLEARLY.
THE STATE SEN HAD TO RATIFY HE
NEEDED TWO THIRDS TO DO SO BUT
THEY WERE ONE STATE SHORT.
THE SOUTHERN STATES WERE OPPOSED
OKAY SO YOU HAD TO MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS SHE SAID WE CAN COUNT
ON THE SOUTHERN STATES WE KNOW
THEY WON'T VOTE FOR IT.
SO WE IF WE JUST PUT THIS UP TO
THE STATE'S THEMSELVES WE SAY
THE STATE SHOULD HAVE THIS RIGHT.
THEN WE DON'T WANT PASS.
THE EFFORT TO LEAVE IT UP TO THE
STATE'S THOUGH AB DIDN'T FLY
WITH CONGRESS.
SO IT CAME DOWN TO TENNESSEE.
TENNESSEE OF ALL STATES.
IN THE VOTE WAS FORTY EIGHT TO
FORTY EIGHT FOUR IN A POST.
AND ONE VOTE.
PUT IT ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
AND THAT WAS FROM TWENTY THREE
OR TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD
REPUBLICAN HARRY T. BURN.
WHO WAS NOT?
COMPLETELY SOLD ON THE IDEA BUT
HIS MOTHER HELPED CONVINCE HIM
TO SUPPORT THE ISSUE.
SO I WOULD SAY ALWAYS LISTEN TO
YOUR MOTHER PARTICULAR IN CASES
LIKE THIS.
I HOPE MY KIDS ARE LISTENING --
SO IT TOOK MORE THAN SIXTY YEARS
THOUGH FOR THE TWELVE REMAINING
STATES TO OFFICIALLY RATIFY.
THIS AMENDMENT.
THE LAST TO STATE TO DO SO WAS
MISSISSIPPI IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR IT'S
KIND OF ASTONISHING TO THINK
THAT.
OVER THE WEEKEND CAL MATTERS PUT
OUT A VERY INTERESTING ARTICLE I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO READ IT BUT I JUST
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT THEY NOTING HERE
WHICH I THOUGHT WERE.
KIND OF FASCINATING AND IN
SOMETHING I DIDN'T KNOW ROSEANNE
VOYAGE A DAUGHTER OF YUGOSLAV AN
INGRID IMMIGRANTS FROM A TINY
TULARE COUNTY TOWN.
BROKE THE GENDER BARRIER IN THE
UPPER HOUSE HERE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX BEFORE HER
THERE HAD BEEN MORE THAN TWELVE
HUNDRED HUNDRED SENATE ELECTIONS
ADDED TAKEN PLACE.
SINCE STATEHOOD AND MEN HAD ONE
ALL OF THEM.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
SO ROSANNE ONE AND THE MEN OF
THE SENATE WERE UNSURE OF HOW TO
HANDLE THEM A WOMAN'S PRESENCE
AND SHE SAID THAT SHE WAS
GREETED WITH NOTHING LESS THAN
SHOCK WHICH DOES NOT SURPRISE ME.
SO SHE BROUGHT A SMALL PORCELAIN%
BELL WITH HER AND KEPT IT AT OUR
DESK WHENEVER ONE OF HER
COLLEAGUES BEGIN A FLOOR SPEECH
WITH GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE.
ROSEANNE WOULD RING HER LITTLE
BELL TO REMIND THEM THAT A LADY
WAS PRESENT IN THE HOUSE AS WELL.
TWO YEARS LATER DIANE WATSON
BECAME THE SENATE FIRST FEMALE
AFRICAN AMERICAN SENATOR.
AND I CAMPAIGN BUYS ADVISER OF
HERS RECALLED TAKING WATSON ON A
MEET AND GREET WITH OTHER BETTER
IN LEGISLATORS AND ONE OF THESE
VETERAN LEGISLATORS PULLED HIM
ASIDE AND SAID. TWO WOMEN IS
ENOUGH.
SO THAT WAS THE ATTITUDE THAT.
WE KNOW THAT THE STRUGGLE FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS MAY HAVE BEEN
LONG AND FRUSTRATING BUT IT WAS
CERTAINLY IN OUR COUNTRY'S BEST
INTEREST.
AFTER FORDING WOMEN THE SAME
RIGHTS AS MEN.
WE SAW MANY OTHER ISSUES OF
EQUALITY.
PASSED THROUGH OUR LEGISLATURE'S
WE SAW THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT WE
SAW THE EQUAL PAY ACT WE SAW THE
BEGINNING OF EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON YOUR
RACE OR SEX RELIGION OR YOUR
GENDER.
AND IF YOU'RE OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER.
AS I AM IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE BILLIE JEAN KING BEAT THE
PANTS OFF A BOBBY RIGGS AND A
NATIONALLY TELEVISED TENNIS
MATCH BECAUSE HE SAID THE
WOMEN'S SPORTS DIDN'T MATCH UP
TO MEN'S AND SHE PROVED WRONG.
SEVENTY ONE NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
SANDRA DAY O'CONNOR WAS SWORN IN
BY PRESIDENT REAGAN AS THE FIRST
WOMAN TO SERVE ON THE SUPREME
COURT.
SALLY RIDE BECAME THE FIRST
AMERICAN WOMAN IN SPACE ON THE
SPACE SHUTTLE ASK -- CHALLENGER.
WHEN I WAS A SOPHOMORE IN HIGH
SCHOOL I SAW THE FIRST FEMALE
VICE PRESIDENT CANDIDATE
GERALDINE FERRARO AND I COULDN'T
BELIEVE WHAT I WAS SEEING THAT
FUNNY THEY HAD A WOMAN?
WHO'S IN WHO'S AT LEAST RUNNING
FOR A POSITION LIKE THAT.
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE CONDOLEEZZA
RICE BECAME THIS COUNTRY'S FIRST
WOMAN TO SERVE AS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER TO PRESIDENT
GEORGE BUSH AND SHE'S ALSO THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN TO
SERVICE SECRETARY STATE.
SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PHENOMENAL
WOMEN THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT
HERE TODAY THESE ARE JUST SOME
OF THEM MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED SOME OF THEM AS WELL
BUT ONE THING WE KNOW IS THAT.
PARTY POLITICS DON'T MATTER
NEARLY AS MUCH AS THE SOLIDARITY
THAT THE WOMEN HAVE ENJOYED
THROUGHOUT HISTORY TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR US TO BE HERE.
SOON MY FELLOW FEMALE
LEGISLATORS THANK YOU FOR DOING
WHAT YOU DO IN FIGHTING THE
FIGHT TO MY MALE COLLEAGUES.
WE ARE PLEASED TO BE SERVING
HERE WITH YOU I URGE AYE ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS MELENDEZ.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION.
MS Là M<c.cyan> AND YOU WOULD LIKE</c>
CO AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLE.
MEMBERS WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR CO AUTHORS.
CISCO AUTHORS ON H. R.. THIRTY
NINE CO AUTHORS AN HR.
THIRTY NINE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLLER SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHOR SAT IN WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
AND FINALLY MEMBERS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN IS A C. R. THIRTY BY
MR SALAS CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
PORTUGUESE NATIONAL HERITAGE
MONTH.
IT'S JUST SALAS YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I PRESENT A C. R. THIRTY
WHICH DECLARES MONTH OF JUNE AS
PORTUGUESE NATIONAL HERITAGE
MONTH IN RECOGNITION OF THEIR
SIGNIFICANT.
CONTRIBUTIONS CALIFORNIA IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
EVERY YEAR THOUSANDS OF
CELEBRATIONS ARE HELD IN HONOR
OF THE HOLY SPIRIT.
AND PORTUGAL'S NATIONAL DAY
WHICH IS JUNE TENTH.
I HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN PORTUGUESE
FESTERS IN MY LOCAL COMMUNITY.
MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO ONE OF
THE LARGEST IF NOT THE LARGEST
PORTUGUESE POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO HONOR
PORTUGUESE AMERICANS WITH THIS
RESOLUTION IN RECOGNITION OF
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE STATE --
THROUGH CULTURE MUSIC ARTS.
COOKING AND OTHER FESTIVITIES ON
A PERSONAL NOTE MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE.
TO WHAT I LIKE TO JUST YOUR
STORY.
I DISCOVERED WHY.
I HAVE AN AFFINITY. FOR THE SALT
BOSS THE FAST US IS BECAUSE I
DID A DNA TEST AND COME TO FIND
OUT I'M PORTUGUESE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS I CAN TELL
YOU IS THAT GOING TO THESE
FESTIVALS AS YOU WON'T FIND
ANOTHER COMMUNITY THAT WILL
WELCOME YOU WITH.
SUCH LOVING AND OPEN ARMS A
COMMUNITY THAT LOVES.
THEIR COMMUNITY THAT LOVES
FAMILIES AND THAT LOVE COMING
TOGETHER AND SHARING THEIR
CULTURE SHARING THE BACKGROUND
SHARING.
HISTORY ABOUT THE AZORES AND SO
WITH THAT -- MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
I'D LOVE TO OPEN THE FIRST ROLE
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS.
SEEING THEIR OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MR SALAS YOU'D LIKE CO AUTHORS
ON THE FIRST ROW CLERK WILL OPEN
THE RIGHT.
THIS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
AUTHORS AND THIS YEAR.
THIRTY THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY NINE
CO AUTHORS.
ADDED IN WITHOUT OBJECTION AND
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MISTER SALAS WE
RETURN TO YOUR FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING.
MARIA DO WHILE LOOP SCORE DOES A
SHE'S PORTUGAL'S CONSUL GENERAL
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
NATION'S LARGEST PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA PORTUGUESE
AMERICAN COALITION.
ALSO IN THE GALLERY JOINING US
TODAY A PORTUGUESE AMERICANS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PORTUGUESE
AMERICAN COALITION.
AND MEMBERS FROM MY DISTRICT AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I LIKE TO ALSO I'D BE REMISS IF
I DID INVITE YOU ALL TO A
RECEPTION WE'RE HAVING UP ON THE
THIRD FLOOR -- RIGHT AFTER
SESSION PLEASE MEMBERS WILL JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING OUR GAS
WE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
WILL BE MEETING AT FOUR FIFTEEN
PM.
IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH THREE S. BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING.
AT FOUR FIFTEEN PM IN ROOM OR
FORTY TWO OH THREE AND THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY JUNE FOURTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY JUNE FIFTH
CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY JUNE SIXTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY JUNE SIXTH AT
NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED